yeah absolutely we need to rethink love
and commitment you know 60 years ago was
when we decided that men had to be
monogamous two men were not monogamous
for all of recorded human history men
had concubines and whores and 60 years
ago straight relationships began to
become more Galit Aryan and was less of
a property transaction a marriage had
been a property transaction for most
recorded human history and it became a
union of two equals and at that moment
instead of deciding to allow women to
have the same sort of freedom and leeway
that men did we decided to let men have
the same limitations impose the same
limitations and women had and we put
monogamous sexual commitment at the
heart of all relationships all long-term
commitments all marriages and we have
watched we should now be able to
recognize the consequences of that which
are a lot of short-term relationships a
lot of divorce because monogamy is
ridiculous and people aren't any good at
it and not wired for it we didn't evolve
to be it's unnatural and it places a
tremendous strain on our marriages and
our long-term commitments to expect them
to be effortlessly monogamous because
what we've said is if you're in love you
shouldn't you won't want to have sex
with anybody else and what we need to
tell people is that if you're in love
you can make a monogamous commitment you
will refrain from having sex with other
people but you will still desperately
want to fuck the shit out of other
people but people understand love means
I don't want to fuck other people
because of these misconceptions pumped
into people's heads about romance love
what it means and so they meet somebody
else that they're attracted to and
they're attracted to the person they
well I must not be in love with my
partner anymore otherwise I wouldn't be
attractive this person or they feel
threatened when their partners are
attracted to other people is if you know
makes them feel insecure and we just
need to get past that and we talk about
monogamy the way we talk about virginity
that you know you're monogamous til you
fuck somebody else and then you're not
ruined it you popped your monogamy hymen
and destroyed your monogamous
relationship we need to talk about
monogamy that we talked about sobriety
which you can be monogamous and fall off
the wagon and then sober back up you can
monogamous back up and get back on the
wagon and the truth of the matter is
that if you're with somebody for 4050
years and they only cheated on you a few
times they were good at being monogamous
not bad at being monogamous they were
good
I do think there needs to be some leeway
and a lot of really good loving
relationships are destroyed because
somebody wants a little variety or isn't
getting a need met and feels they have
to step out and it explodes the
relationship I'm conservative I think
that we should do what we can to
preserve marriages and long term
relationships and one way to do that is
to encourage people have more realistic
attitudes about sexual exclusivity